[Música]
bien muy buenos días a todos ustedes
para mí un verdadero honor estar aquí
como bien decía freddy me llamo
francisco domínguez brito muchos me
conocen por haber ocupado algunas
funciones públicas como fiscal del
distrito o procurador general de la
república un toque también en el
ministerio de trabajo con el ministerio
de medio ambiente y también como senador
por la provincia de santiago
es mi primera vez que participo en este
tipo de eventos como el teeti para mí
también significa un gran honor y si es
como dice freddy de verdad que para mí
sería un gran honor que me invitaron
nuevamente pero ya como presidente de la
república
inicia la introducción porque
básicamente quiero hablar de algunas
vivencias experiencias a través de los
años en diferentes instituciones
públicas y no les niego que la fiscalía
del distrito tal vez fue la función
donde más impacto tuvo en mi vida sobre
todo en hechos relevantes que son los
que van marcando el devenir a uno de
nosotros
nunca olvido cuando asumí las funciones
la primera noche en la cual tomaba
juramento en el palacio nacional yo
venía de santiago tenía 31 años no había
tenido experiencia pública y mucho menos
en santo domingo y recuerdo que al
juramentar me habían 20 30 fotógrafos
fueron muchos las flash en horas de la
noche que fue la juramentación yo dure
más de 30 minutos viendo en imita como
decimos en santiago fue mi primera
experiencia y yo dije guau qué será esto
qué es lo que a mí me espera y así
fueron las primeras semanas
al ocupar unas funciones en un momento
de conflicto donde sectores de la
sociedad civil los sectores de la prensa
no estaban de acuerdo con la entrada de
este muchacho de 31 años a un puesto tan
importante tenía la prensa a mi
alrededor desde las siete y media de la
mañana cuando yo llegaba ocupaba siempre
primeras planas en los periódicos
realmente en el centro de atención en
ese momento en un momento determinado
una semana y media después sólo semanas
después iba subiendo la escalera del
palacio de justicia de ciudad nueva y
siempre digo esto porque hay gente que
tiene fe cree en dios otros que no yo no
sé cómo lo pueda llamar cada quien para
mí fue una especie de mensaje divino de
yo me detuve en medio de la escalera
me pare y como que algo me decía no te
creas importante
no te creas la gran cosa el hecho de que
toda esta semana te está girando
alrededor de ti todo esto no significa
que sea tú es la función no significa
que te que tú eres superior a los demás
simplemente es una coyuntura y no les
niego que me marco enormemente para todo
el devenir el sentido de realidad de
saber exactamente lo que uno es y por
qué uno está y el uno no creerse que
verdaderamente está por encima de todas
las cosas una semana después de esa
experiencia y como les digo me marco me
llamaron de la dirección de aduanas no
teníamos vehículo en la fiscalía del
distrito y yo había solicitado un
vehículo la dirección de aduanas y el
único vehículo que existía era un
mercedes benz del año en ese momento de
dos puertas yo me reí no les niego que
siempre hay una tentación 31 años su
mercedes benz del año de dos puertas
pero inmediatamente le dije a don miguel
cocco que en ese momento en el
directorio aduanas mire don miguel yo
prefiero que no me dé ese vehículo no
que sea apto para este tipo de funciones
no es austero creo que se vería muy mal
ellos tuviera ese tipo de vehículos y
eso me me reforzó en esa autoestima de
valorar las cosas esenciales de la vida
y no aquellas que simplemente son un
fantasma una pantalla una careta que a
veces creemos que es nuestra realidad la
fiscalía me permitió ver muchas cosas en
la vida desde una mamá que porque su
niña se portaba mal le tomo su manito la
puso en la estufa y le quemó las manos
para sancionarla
vi casos tan serios como otra mamá que
le puso una querella al novio de la hija
porque se enteró que habían tenido
relaciones sexuales y ella no podía
pensar que en la comunidad en su barrio
se enterarán que su hija mayor de edad
con 18 o 19 años había tenido relaciones
con un muchacho que era su novio y lo
acusó de violación y vi llorando a todas
estas personas para que ese muchacho
vaya preso y luego vi llorando a todas
estas personas para que soltaran a ese
muchacho de la cárcel vi el dolor de una
madre de ver que su hijo duró unos años
presos sin un expediente fue acusado
simplemente por error y todo eso me fue
a mí diciendo como en la vida solamente
aquello que tú haces para ayudar para
servir o para cambiar la vida del otro
te da un tipo de sentido
la grandeza y tal vez es esa la primera
enseñanza que yo pudiera transmitir o la
primera experiencia no está en las
grandes cosas en los grandes titulares
ni en las famas ni en el poder está en
las cosas pequeñas que poco a poco poco
a poco van transformando y hacen las
cosas grandes y ahí yo pasé a ocupar
funciones
en el sector privado cuando hubo cambio
de gobierno inmediatamente
aspire a la senaduría por la provincia
de santiago y de nuevo como que dios o
la vida te va dando señales de que uno
tiene que ubicarse en los sitios donde
uno está recuerda en un momento
determinado yo en uno de los mítines
llegaba a un barrio lleno de gente y
mucha gente aplaudiendo y a mí me
aplaudían y yo me iba creyendo también
sumamente importante
porque había sobre todo una señora que
también hacía mucha reverencia mucho
saludo y mucha alegría al final ella me
da un abrazo muy admirada de estar
frente a mí y me dice caramba pero te
apoyo siempre te quiero mucho pero don
hipólito usted si está demacrado
y yo me quedé como wow yo creía que era
mi
y así uno va pasando en la política y en
la vida esas sensaciones de uno entender
que la vida es un transcurrir y que uno
no debe creerse la gran cosa luego fui
pasando de funciones en funciones y no
les niego que el ministerio de medio
ambiente marcó mucho en mi vida sobre
todo algunas situaciones que ahí yo pude
vivir y pongo siempre el ejemplo de los
tortugas tinglares tal vez fue una de
las cosas que a mí más me impactó yo no
sé si ustedes saben pero una tortuga
tinglar es más o menos de mi tamaño es
más grande en algunos casos
y nace en un lugar determinado en una
playa determinada de una población
determinada de una isla determinada y
durante cinco diez quince veinte años
esa tortuga tinglar comienza a recorrer
todos los mares del mundo alaska en
desgracia puede ser áfrica recoge todos
los mares del mundo y saben que 20 años
después esa tortuga tinglar decide que
debe continuar la procreación y que debe
de poner sus huevos y desovar en una
playa y adivinen a qué playa va la
tortura' titular
ella puede estar en los mares de china'
y algo que no es un ep s ni no se sabe
qué ni cómo explicar le dice tienes que
ir al mismo lugar donde naciste y esa
tortuga tinglar que nació en bahía de
las águilas desde los mares de china'
comienza toda una travesía y va a
aquella isla de la española donde la
acción pero no va ni siquiera a la playa
de samaná ni a libia ni a ningún otro
lugar donde también nacen las centenares
va al mismo lugar al mismo lugar donde
esa singular nació
y uno entonces comienza
[Música]
apreciar y tal vez al otro punto que yo
quisiera que quede en nuestros corazones
y es el mirar como la admiración a algo
nos hace sentir más personas en ese
momento nosotros en bahía de las águilas
recuerdo una noche hermosa donde uno
sentía que le agarraba las manos a una
estrella y que como digo yo hasta la
luna se ponía celosa porque al esperar
esa emoción de que la tortuga iba a
poner esos huevos y luego ver esos
pequeños salir corriendo hacia el mar y
uno pensar que solamente uno de cada uno
de ellos sobrevive 15 o 20 años entre
cada mil y tú pensar que aquí había
personas que se robaba esos huevos de
las tortugas tinglares para venderlo en
400 pesos para que la gente hiciera unos
huevos revueltos que supuestamente
podían tener algún impacto
las cosas del cuerpo o de la naturaleza
de las personas
entonces si no admiramos eso que tenemos
si nosotros no apreciamos aquello que
nos da la vida tampoco tiene sentido la
misma existencia de ellos hoy hay
grandes retos aquí con nosotros hay
grandes retos en materia de medio
ambiente retos que pueden incluso
complicar nuestra existencia como nación
hace poco yo tuve la oportunidad de
visitar puerto príncipe y conocer más de
lleno el tema del agua en puerto
príncipe
esa situación me motivó que en cada
evento internacional llámese la cumbre
de cambio climático cualquiera en el
cual yo me encontraba siempre el tema de
haití debió y tenía que ser uno de los
temas esenciales de mis motivaciones yo
no sé si ustedes saben pero puerto
príncipe- tiene una población de
aproximadamente 3 millones de habitantes
que está experimentando una migración
muy grande del campo hacia la ciudad más
el crecimiento poblacional se estima que
vamos a tener una población el puerto
príncipe- de cada 7 o de aproximadamente
7 millones de habitante en 10 años el
puerto príncipe sólo el xi por ciento
sólo el 5 por ciento de sus casas tienen
o ducha o lavamanos todas las demás son
simplemente pozos pozos están a dos o
tres esquinas de cada una de sus casas
pozos que están al lado de las letrinas
lo que yo quiero decir y así lo dije en
un evento público es que en puerto
príncipe no hay mucha diferencia entre
bañarse con el agua de pozo y bañarse
con el agua de la letrina
el tema de la insalubridad el tema de
las dificultades el tema de la intro
introducción salina que se está dando
cuando la falta de agua en las aguas
subterráneas se produce y el mar entra
por todos los ductos y hace que en la
llanura de puerto príncipe- muchas de
las aguas ya sean salada y tampoco se
puedan utilizar
yo me pregunto yo me pregunto qué será
de puerto príncipe en diez años si
realmente el cambio climático es una
realidad que será de puerto príncipe si
tenemos una sequía de 45 años como se
vivió en guatemala recientemente o en
centroamérica qué sucedería con una
población que pueda verse verdaderamente
en un estado crítico de sé cuál es la
situación para la republica dominica y
ahí yo hablo de una solidaridad tal vez
una solidaridad egoísta puede ser porque
está en riesgo la misma convivencia de
nuestro país con otra nación hermana
pero también una solidaridad real de
saber que hombres y mujeres pueden verse
en una situación tan lamentable tan
crítica tan
a una serie de enfermedades que pueden
poner en riesgo su propia sobrevivencia
y cuando yo digo de solidaridad yo no
estoy hablando de una funda de comida
para llevarla ni siquiera de una funda
de medicinas es la responsabilidad
global que tenemos que tener cada uno de
los ciudadanos con el medio ambiente la
mayoría de los ríos que alimentan la
presa de peligro
qué es la única presa que tiene haití
que alimenta también el valle de
artibonité se alimenta de los ríos
artibonito y macasías que son los dos
ríos que tiene y que nacen en la
república dominicana si nosotros no
cuidamos nuestras aguas si nosotros no
cuidamos nuestros bosques nosotros
estamos poniendo en riesgo lo que es la
sobrevivencia de un país hermano pero lo
mismo sucede con nosotros mismos hoy tal
vez valle nuevo es uno de los centros
más importantes de discusión ahí nacen
la mayor parte de las aguas que nosotros
consumimos
nosotros estamos hablando de que siete
de cada diez dominicanos disfrutan de
una manera u otra de las aguas de valle
nuevo y saben que vaya nuevo yo pensaba
que era un lugar que llovía a torrentes
porque bueno es la fuente principal de
las aguas finalmente no lugares como los
haitíses tienen mayor pluviometría que
valle nuevo valle nuevo simplemente
canta todas las aguas de una manera
espectacular
es toda una montaña donde existe una
neblina inmensa y donde esa neblina al
contacto con los árboles se condensan do
y van bajando poquito a poquito gotitas
de rocío y esas gotitas de rocío van
convirtiéndose en pequeños manantiales y
en arroyos y posteriormente en los ríos
que nosotros hoy nos permite disfrutar
sus aguas cada una de las aguas con las
cuales ustedes se bañaron hoy en la
mañana o aún la que consumimos en gran
medida proviene del valle nuevo romper
quitar destruir aquello que nos da la
vida indudablemente que es uno de los
crímenes más grandes que nosotros
podemos hacer por eso yo digo que vaya
nuevo es agradecer es agradecer a la
naturaleza y el agradecimiento a la
naturaleza se hace con acciones se hace
con acciones claras y precisas de cuidar
aquello que tenemos y de reparar aquello
que hemos dañado de cuidar todo aquello
que nos circunda y que nos va a permitir
lo mejor para las generaciones que viene
yo simplemente quería compartir estas
experiencias decirles que a lo largo del
trabajo público al final lo más
importante no es lo que uno se cree no
es salir dos veces en el periódico o tal
vez ser invitado a un evento tan
importante como este lo más importante
es servir y trabajar con aquellas
pequeñas cosas y que esas pequeñas cosas
sean las que puedan construir las
grandes cosas que podamos
yo creo que la admiración es una de las
cualidades más grandes que puede tener
el ser humano porque lo que nos permite
disfrutar todo lo que nos rodea
solidario solidario con aquel espera de
nosotros sí que no hay tal vez más nadie
que lo pueda hacer y finalmente
agradecer que la vida sea un
agradecimiento que mi existencia sea un
agradecimiento de lo que soy de lo que
he sido de lo que me ha dado todo lo que
me rodea
en fin agradecer el renacido agradecer
el hecho de vivir muchísimas gracias a
todos ustedes